Lindsey is with us in Kansas hi Lindsey
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call sure so my
husband I have been talking about this
for a little while as we know a
deployment is coming up he will be
leaving at the end of this year kind of
for probably almost a year long
deployment overseas with that being said
right now we actually have three
vehicles I direct the van with the kids
and we have a commuter car because he
drives about 60 miles to work every day
to his base and so we have a fuel
efficient economy car for him and then
we also have a pickup club cabs I think
we've had for a while the car and the
pickup of those paid off the van we have
payment on but we do have nothing saying
as we could pay it off my question and I
guess his was to and we are on opposite
sides of the question I guess is should
we get rid of one of my vehicles while
he's gone for a whole year I mean we
have three vehicles and there would be
one of me that's needing a vehicle yeah
I suspect that the only one up up for
grabs is the commuter car right or the
pickup I mean truly the commuter car is
the one that I'm heating he'll probably
use when he gets back but you know it's
also the pickup the pickup is worth what
Oh probably 10 to 15 what is the
commuter car worth mmm five to eight I
just made five sizes and what's your
household income Oh God 215 okay well
the only reason to get rid of it is the
savings on insurance and the loss of
value while it sits there so how much
does it how much does a $12,000 pickup
go off in value in one year a couple of
grand so not a big deal for somebody
making 215 right okay so if you little
if you like both cars and they're
reasonable cars and they're the same car
you buy when you get back if you think
about trading anyway I mean be time to
get rid of one
now and then just buy whatever you want
to buy when you get home right but if
you're not if you were just gonna if you
said I hope they're both sitting there
when I get home there's not a real
financial thing that's driving you to
sell them because the losses of value
and insurance and tags during one year
is not going to [ __ ] a two hundred
thousand dollar income family right so
you know I'm ambivalent about it but III
kind of see that that you know whoever
it is is arguing to get rid of them
because it's wasteful that kind of kind
of feels that way that's kind of an
emotional feeling about it but the
actual dollars that you're wasting are
not a bunch so but again if you were
gonna trade anytime soon
you know like for instance if he wanted
to buy a little better truck after you
all hit some financial goals or
something
I'd probably dump that I'd probably get
rid of that truck and then when you get
home just drive the commuter car for
another year and then buy the thirty
thousand dollar truck you're thinking
about buying or whatever you know if you
were going to do if you're gonna do
something like that then I'd go ahead
and dump it now so you don't have the
loss during the year but if you're gonna
drive that truck for five more years I
probably let it sit there okay and I pay
off a van today Lindsay I know I know
we need to I it's just sitting there
it's gaining interest yeah we could we
could pay it off today today tell him
thanks for his service in you too kiddo
thank